[Music]
on this saturday night dangerous weather
putting lives at risk
as extreme heat and wildfires scorch
parts of california this heat is
killing us concern grows over the
state's power grid plus on the ground in
pakistan canadian efforts to help as the
death toll and displacement from
historic flooding climbs mission aborted
why nasa's artemis one moon launch is
cancelled launch director charlie
blackwell thompson has called a scrub
for a second time in a week
[Applause]
[Music]
the end of a brilliant career
these are happy tears i guess
and tennis icon serena williams impact
on the next generation
global national with bara nasser
reporting tonight colleen christie
good evening thanks for joining us the
catastrophic effects of climate change
are on full display tonight on opposite
sides of the globe in pakistan more than
33 million people are now affected by
devastating floods while in california
the state already in a deep drought
heads into the worst of its fire season
and that's where we begin our coverage
as jennifer johnson reports some
residents are literally fleeing for
their lives
california is literally burning up
thousands have been ordered to evacuate
as the so-called mill fire rages out of
control many residents had almost no
time to collect their belongings when
the emergency order to get out was
issued just a couple of backpacks
clothes on our back our my youngest son
don't even have shoes on his feet rapid
rate of spread and now just across an
interstate from the mill fire another
wildfire has broken out the mountain
fire more residents in that area have
been told to leave too
the fires and smoke are shutting down
major highways holiday travelers heading
north this weekend are being warned to
take precautions emergency roadside kits
i highly recommend have a phone charger
with you
and water because this heat is killing
us deadly high temperatures are
threatening lives not only in california
but in several other nearby states it's
become unbearable for residents of this
san fernando valley senior mobile home
park which lost power thursday night
it's terrible the heat is just it's just
it's killing me the intense heat is too
much for the power grid in many areas
residents are being urged to turn up
their air conditioning thermostats to
cut electricity use outside los angeles
officials are warning of rolling
blackouts between sunday and tuesday
what we're trying to do is lessen the
effect on our load and if we can do
those and do them spirally that would
help us not to have bigger outage
the heat is so suffocating emergency
crews are responding to hundreds of heat
related calls a day officials are
warning people to stay inside from 10
a.m to 6 p.m well i'm canadian so i'm
not really built for this heat
i'm going to try and wear a light color
on like this black shirt today and drink
a lot of water that's my goal millions
of others are sharing that goal as this
end of summer long weekend scorches
parts of the u.s west
jennifer johnson global news washington
in alberta crews are working to control
a lightning-caused wildfire in jasper
national park it started overnight
thursday fire control lines were put in
place early this morning to protect
power lines to the town of jasper no
communities are at risk but environment
canada has issued a special air quality
statement and in bc there's a new
wildfire about eight kilometers west of
penticton officials say the blue
mountain wildfire is currently out of
control and is suspected to be human
caused
to pakistan now were a flooding crisis
of unimaginable proportions continues to
unfold the united nations says record
monsoon rains have already caused more
than 1200 deaths and the situation is
expected to get worse the world health
organization estimates more than 6.4
million people are in dire need of
humanitarian aid and with infrastructure
heavily damaged in parts of the country
pakistani officials are pleading for
help from the international community
tonight brittany rosen reports on how
some canadians are stepping up
left with nothing boats carry a
microscopic fraction of the 33 million
pakistanis affected by catastrophic
floods
this footage captured firsthand by
winnipegger mazur khan who is on the
ground to help i have seen some some
areas where literally people are just
you know sitting under the sky and they
don't have any shelter starting in
islamabad khan says he is traveling to
relief camps at badly hit regions along
the indus river providing food supplies
and service where needed i have
flashbacks from the 2010 floods when
something similar happened this is of a
higher magnitude and i know the flight
of the people back in 2010 and you know
definitely compelled me to you know go
back
khan is again tasked with helping those
caught in the crossroad of a climate
disaster and a humanitarian crisis which
has left more than 1200 dead and an
estimated 10 billion dollars u.s worth
of damage the scale of devastation is
massive
and requires immense humanitarian
response for
33 million people for this i appeal
to my fellow pakistanis
pakistani expatriates
and the international community
to help pakistan in this hour of need
ravaging flood waters have also caused a
health crisis creating an ideal climate
for waterborne illnesses and leaving
hundreds of thousands of pregnant women
potentially in need of care things like
cholera typhoid e coli infections and
these these can be devastating
especially when so many people are
exposed in such a short period of time
which is why we're making sure that we
get people clean drinking water canadian
organizations like global medic are
acting quickly to send humanitarian aid
that includes water purification units
the canadian government has so far
pledged five million dollars towards the
crisis in pakistan which will go towards
food and cash assistance for those who
are most severely impacted officials
tell global news they continue to
monitor the situation and stand ready to
provide additional assistance based on
needs brittany rosen global news toronto
with millions of pakistanis struggling
climate change experts say the world
should be on high alert as kamiya razavi
explains similar events are happening
more frequently and in our own backyard
if you think what happened in pakistan
can't happen closer to home think again
that was the un secretary general's
ominous warning today
it is pakistan
tomorrow it could be your country well
it's kind of crass but uh when i see
pictures like that it's like well we
told you so
jennifer francis is among the 97 percent
of the world scientists who are warning
of the dangers of human-caused climate
change
these extremely heavy precipitation
events are much more frequent
and they're happening really all over
the world now that's because as the
planet warms more water off the oceans
and also off land is being released into
the atmosphere it acts like another
greenhouse gas literally juicing storms
and making them more powerful so as the
planet warms up the water water the
capacity of the atmosphere to hold water
vapor is going to go up and that is
basically uh you know leading to events
like this there were the storms that
pounded germany last year
the atmospheric rivers that drenched bc
last fall
and hurricane harvey that stalled over
houston in 2017 and that's to say
nothing of more heat waves
experts fear climate change means that
weather extremes like the one pakistan
is experiencing will only get worse we
expect that the whole monsoon system
like the whole monsoon circulation south
asian monsoon circulation would
intensify fueling the need to be better
prepared for a changing and more
dangerous world
kamiyar razavi global news
the biggest oil sands producers in the
country say they're feeling hopeful
after meetings with the deputy prime
minister this week the industry which is
responsible for most of canada's
greenhouse gas emissions is looking for
a massive investment from ottawa to help
it decarbonize it's asking for tens of
billions of federal dollars to build a
carbon capture and storage operation in
northern alberta but as heather urex
west explains critics say public money
is better spent elsewhere
it was a meeting that lasted only an
hour this week in calgary the deputy
prime minister a room full of energy
ceos and one pretty hard sell really
thrilled that she made the time while
she was in calgary to meet with pathways
and our six ceos
really productive conversation we are
aligned
in our objective to
execute these big carbon decarbonization
projects
last year the country's largest oil
producers came together to form the oil
sands pathway to net zero initiative a
plan to get the industry to net zero by
2050 using mainly carbon capture
utilization and storage or cc us it's
really critted critically needed
technology to be
implemented as quickly as possible for
the short or intermediate term reduction
of emissions but if cc us is going to
cut canada's emissions in any
significant way infrastructure needs to
ramp up dramatically and fast the
pathways to net zero proposal will cost
tens of billions of dollars and the
industry doesn't want to pay for it
alone
for months it's been asking ottawa to
invest but so far the answer has been no
i don't think there's any appetite among
canadians to invest more taxpayers money
in what is really the company's
responsibility to decarbonize their own
their own industry it's a sentiment
that's been echoed by canada's
environment minister after several tough
years for producers high oil prices mean
the industry is once again a wash in
cash with plenty of money to invest
alberta 2 is reaping the rewards
reporting a 13.2 billion dollar surplus
this week these are sans companies are
dealing with uh record profits
record free cash flow they have the
technology and what we really need to
see is just
them to make the investments themselves
to to support their own future but the
industry warns it's not that simple most
companies operating in canada are major
multinationals with interests and
operations in places like the us where
incentives to decarbonize are growing
they've now gone and doubled the
previous incentives they had in place
for
many of these decarbonation
decarbonization activities including
carbon capture and storage if we can't
have a level playing field
investment dollars will flow there but
the feds are making no promises as
ottawa tries to balance the country's
climate commitments with its economic
and energy security needs heather urex
west global news calgary
europe's largest nuclear plant in
ukraine has been knocked off line again
the head of the u.n nuclear watchdog
says the russian-controlled zaparisian
nuclear plant was disconnected after
sustained shelling in the area agency
experts say the fourth and last
operational line is down the three
others were lost earlier during the
conflict there is one reserve line from
a nearby thermal plant delivering the
electricity the plant generates to the
external grid the zaparisia facility has
been held by russian forces since early
march but its ukrainian staff is still
operating it in moscow thousands stood
in line to pay their final respects to
the last leader of the soviet union
mikhail gorbachev a public farewell
ceremony was held for gorbachev who died
this week at the age of 91. russian
president vladimir putin did not attend
claiming he was busy gorbachev launched
reforms that helped end the cold war he
also precipitated the breakup of the
soviet union which putin has called the
20th century's greatest geopolitical
catastrophe
coming up matchmaking to buy real estate
the growing popularity of co-home
ownership
with home prices skyrocketing during the
pandemic more and more people are
looking for alternative routes to
ownership in particular home
co-ownership is gaining attention it was
once an uncommon arrangement between
family friends or even strangers pooling
their money to buy a home but now as ann
gaviola explains it's seeing a surge in
popularity
hello
hi how are you welcome to the housemates
co-ownership event this mixer in toronto
is no ordinary social event it's for a
unique clientele people open to buying a
home in partnership with other people
sometimes complete strangers this is by
the folks behind the housemates platform
which connects prospective co-homeowners
it's like matchmaking bumble hinge or
tinder for real estate
it's not a romantic dating app it's
strictly for owning property together
it's gone from novel and niche to an
increasingly popular option for those
who feel priced out of the housing
market co-ownership seems to be
on everyone's mind housing prices are
increasing inflation gas prices people's
incomes have not met those increases for
a long time in the city of toronto and
i'd say vancouver
corrine kempster and his family are very
interested in co-owning their first home
the city has changed a lot in 15 years
and
we just simply can't afford
a home on our own so they're mingling
hoping to find a good fit we've been
talking with myself and my wife about
like what we want out of it
what we're looking for
what our ideal setup would be legal
experts who can help make it happen are
here naturally design and construction
experts too we tend to think of one
family a house but does it have to be
that way
and how can we promote it so that
you have an element of sharing so you
have an intentional community built into
your own house proponents say it's part
of a solution to the housing crisis in
canada's most expensive cities it's
such a huge relief to know that you
don't have to bear all the expenses
yourself you don't have to go through
the mortgage application yourself you're
not in hundreds of thousands of dollars
in debt yourself and an antidote to a
so-called epidemic of loneliness
exacerbated by the pandemic we have
great neighbors where we are right now
but it would be
even better to take that kind of the
next level and have really close
neighbors that you can maybe rely on and
they can rely on you the best of both
worlds all under one roof and gaviola
global news toronto
ahead the battle to save lives in
canada's deadliest epidemic
it's an epidemic many canadians would
rather ignore for years the opioid
crisis has shattered families and
communities across the country taking
lives in every age and socio-economic
demographic since 2016 more than 29 000
people have died as a result of drug
toxicity as rachel gilmore reports
advocates on the front lines of this
epidemic are once again pushing for more
awareness hoping it will save lives
every day 21 canadians die from opioid
overdoses the frantic fight to save
lives is being waged across the country
it's impossible
any day of the week to not hear about
somebody who has died but there are
concerns years into this opioid crisis
the battle is being lost in silence
everything but families of overdose
victims and canadian senator vern white
want to raise public awareness about the
severity of the crisis they're asking
prime minister justin trudeau to lower
the flag on parliament hill to
acknowledge those who die each day so
far that hasn't happened including this
week during international overdose
awareness day i don't hold a lot of hope
i think actually that
many are afraid to talk about it they
they don't want to get into the
discussion about who is impacted
in the first full year of the pandemic
alone there was a 96 percent increase in
opioid deaths nationally with more than
7 500 deaths in 2021 alone it's
impossible wendy muckle is the ceo of
inner city health which operates a safe
consumption site in ottawa she has
experienced the cruelty of the opioid
crisis firsthand it's like we're in a
war inside this whole other world and
nobody else really knows that we're at
war
she says there are concrete steps all
levels of government can take to better
address this growing problem including
decriminalizing possession of small
amounts of drugs
chad boutilier works at a safe
consumption site while he supports calls
to draw more public attention to opioid
deaths he says action is also needed
lowering a flag is is not going to stop
people dying
i think a lot of things have to happen
in a statement the government did not
acknowledge the calls to lower the flag
instead noting several buildings across
canada were flooded with purple light
wednesday to increase overdose awareness
and ottawa isn't committing to any new
action
advocates are urging the government to
move now because every day that they
wait for changes more canadians are
dying rachel gilmore global news ottawa
the second launch attempt
of the space launch system
and orion spacecraft
has been scrubbed
a fuel leak was blamed for once again
keeping nasa's new artemis one moon
rocket grounded today the test flight is
part of the space agency's renewed lunar
exploration goals in which canada is
playing a key role
this is our team swan the first of a
series of missions the artemis program
the second flight with crew is going to
have a canadian space agency astronaut
on board so
huge for our nation
this first uncrewed mission has until
tuesday to take off or face being
delayed until october
one incredible journey has come to an
end for one of the world's biggest
sports stars tennis icon serena williams
has played what is likely her last
professional match and she did not go
quietly the 23-time grand slam champion
was defeated in the third round of the
u.s open after a grueling three-hour
game kamel carameli looks back on serena
williams game-changing career
the end of a dream run at the u.s open
leading to the end of an era
just
everyone that's here that's been on my
side so many years decades oh my gosh
literally decades after 23 grand slam
singles titles the most by any player in
the open era serena williams hung up her
racket for good friday and the tributes
came pouring in from the king of the
basketball court it's unprecedented and
um it's been an honor
to watch your journey to women's tennis
legend billie jean king her incredible
career made its mark on tennis history
to a new generation hoping to follow in
her footsteps it's because of you i
believe in this dream former u.s first
lady michelle obama also tweeting how
lucky were we to be able to watch a
young girl from compton grow up to
become one of the greatest athletes of
all time serena's impact on canadian
soil undeniable winning the canadian
title three times the last one happening
in 2013.
still the last american woman to win in
canada she's played our tournament for
over 20 years
and i see all the young kids that she
influences here we go
for young canadians watching her win
also meant watching the game change more
diversity and inclusion on the tennis
court i just looked up to her all the
time she
like being a woman of color i don't
think she's leaving a whole i think
she's living like a legacy canadian
teens who weren't even born when
williams won her first grand slam title
now hoping to learn from that legacy
even when she stops now i feel like
she's going to keep inspiring
generations to come
you know for her to come from absolutely
nothing and to achieve the success that
she has is uh very inspiring now the 40
year old plans to grow her family and
her other business ventures building a
different legacy off the court kamal
karamali global news that's global
national for this saturday night i'm
colleen christie tonight your canada is
this beautiful time lapse of the sunset
at vancouver sunset beach of course we
love seeing your canada please keep
emailing your photos to viewers at
globalnational.com
thanks for watching i hope to see you
back here again tomorrow good night
[Music]